alors les émeutes en novembre sont en
train de devenir une tradition non savez
c'est un peu les dictateurs lorsqu'ils
veulent prendre le pouvoir il commence
par brûler les écoles et les livres et
exterminer les intellectuels et bien
lorsque dans un quartier une petite
minorité de voyous brute de les écoles
ils nuisent et pénalise les les jeunes
qui habitent dans leur quartier et donc
ça c'est terrible donc il faut
absolument être extrêmement sévère au
regard de tout ça vous êtes sérieuse
quand vous dites que sérieusement que
vous comparez aux dictateurs oui oui
mais c'est ça aussi la dictature de la
violence des enfants pour le et cote et
quand quand on viole pas fait pas
possible de dire un truc quand on brille
quand on brûle des écoles quand on brûle
des ego à dire quand on brûle une
bibliothèque c'est la dictature de la
violence pour mon nom parce que la
dictature la violence elle commence par
exemple quand on voit des propos de
sarkozy qui a des attitudes parfois qui
sont pas du tout pacifique qui sont
extrêmement violentes dans son
comportement on peut pas générer la paix
dans ce genre de fin dans sept ce
comportement humain si vous voulez c'est
normal c'est un enchaînement de choses
non mais non mais non mais ça veut dire
c'est ce qu'ils ont de la république on
m'a dit ne pas avoir certaines attitudes
par rapport à des événements et de
traiter des gens et de dire mais descend
là on peut pas faire ça quand on les
présente la république s'est pas posée
non c'est pas possible je veux dire
parce que je vous prends heureux
résultat prévient le centre d'état
je suis pas madame célarié je suis même
osé célarié
comédienne on me dit mademoiselle
comme ceux dont vous parlez dictature
mais moi mon fils et les métis appel à
brac diallo il a 22 ans que tu avais
trop c'est pas lui qui est le dictateur
jamais c'est lui parce que sa peau est
noire et que toute façon c'est le
merdier avec la plupart de ces gosses ne
représente pas la banlieue on s'est tous
les deux et la plupart cessé d enfants à
11 ans t'es pas un dictateur et taquin
on va dire plus et
raffole h moi c'est que les gosses il ya
un vrai problème vous le savez très bien
c'est qu'on les considère comme des
aides comme des gens de seconde zone
faut pas s'étonner 6,6 comportent comme
des gens de seconde zone séance pour moi
rien l'excusent excuse moi te dire ça
clément mais y'a un truc qui m'étonnait
moi je suis pas du tout d'accord avec ce
que dit mr le député jeu plutôt d'accord
avec toi j'ai toujours voté à gauche
mais charrie tout et c'est marrant que
retient le mot dictateur ça comme si les
mots on aurait le droit de nous de les
employer des gens de droite et de le
moniteur un mec droite un chalet en bois
de l'employé dès qu'ils le disent et
comment vous permet de traiter ce jeune
de diktat aurions etc mais posez lui la
question directe est ce que tu as envie
d'ouvrir le rideau tout simplement
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'institut abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux